an american journalist is caught up in
the deadly assault on democracy in
myanmar
the southeast asian country once known
as burma
a military coup that began four months
ago has left hundreds dead and thousands
imprisoned
including leisures of the leaders rather
of the country's elected government
the regime is also detaining journalists
including danny fenster
he is 37 a michigan native who's been
working in myanmar for years
he was taken into custody last week at
the yangon international airport
while waiting for a flight to leave the
country
finster's mother rose and his brother
brian are calling for his release
and they join us now to discuss good
morning to you rose and brian i can't
imagine how worried you all must be
so i thank you so much for taking the
time you know a lot of people listening
to you today this will be the first time
that they're hearing
about what has happened to to danny so
let's give the back story
rose how did you first hear that he had
been detained
um i think it's nine days ago a week ago
monday morning
7 a.m my son here brian
called us and he had received some
messages
early morning that from danny's wife
in myanmar that he had been detained and
couldn't get a hold of her but did get a
hold of one of danny's co-workers who
filled him
in that he was being detained
and taken to insane prison so
that's how it all started and now and
now here we are brian exactly what were
you talking first tell us
who was he working for how long had he
been there what exactly was he doing
in august of 2020 uh he started working
at frontier
myanmar he was a managing editor there
so he was
at his desk editing stories uh making
sure the
burmese translations to english were
were correct
so he's not someone who was out on the
streets normally
uh no no he was he was at his desk he
was never at
any protest or on the streets reporting
so why do you think that they decided to
take him into custody
it's all speculative right now um we're
we're on day 10
and we we don't have any confirmation of
anything
it can only be assumed because he's a
journalist in a country
where they want to uh you know shut shut
them up essentially
that um that he was detained
because rose i heard that he was
actually at the airport he had gotten
through security
he was about to board the plane why was
he deciding do you know why he was
deciding to come back to the states at
that particular time
yes to my knowledge he was supposed to
come home in july for a visit
we haven't seen him in over three years
to surprise
his parents us my son his niece and
nephew
his 95 year old grandmother who's a
holocaust survivor
and he and my son brian were talking and
this was a surprise to come in early
like this to surprise us
so yes heartbreaking it is heartbreaking
rose it is
you hadn't seen him in three years it's
different when you haven't seen him in
three years and you know he's safe
as opposed to now he's coming home to
surprise the family
and it appears he may be in danger
although we don't know that for sure
what are you hearing brian from the
biden administration
we we haven't spoken directly with them
but the
we have been in contact regular contact
with the state department and the
embassy
uh in in myanmar everyone's been
extremely responsive to all of our
requests we're just
there's a lack of information right now
they put in a request
10 days ago for consular access for
danny
which they should be granted and they
have had they haven't even
had a reply to the request yet now i
heard something that
that struck me as strange that the state
department can't really give you
information
until they get permission from danny to
give you information about his status
is that true that's correct and that's
um to protect danny's privacy uh which
we understand
and unfortunately in myanmar there's a
regime that's in power
and from our sense there's not much
protocol
and information and processes move
very slowly so what can people do to
help you at this
at this point rose and brian what can
what can what do you want people to do
keep this story alive that danny is
needs to be free and sent home
uh there's a petition that's out it's uh
yeah yeah i mean journalism is part of a
thriving society
and we're trying to speak out danny's
name on behalf of that cause as well
we need this story to stay fresh in the
news cycle we don't want him to be
forgotten
naturally unfortunately that's that's
what happens uh
so we are asking people to share on
their socials we have a hashtag bring
danny home
webpage a website we also have a bring
danny home.com
uh website what's kind of like a hub for
everything related to this and they can
also link out to a moveon.org petition
we have
again all to raise awareness and urge
the administration to
to make this move a little quicker it's
important that you speak up so he has
not forgotten rose how are you getting
through this
it's minute by minute with
such support with support from my family
family and friends community um
danny's wife from myanmar just
beyond the world this supported by being
able to speak and get it out on
tv on national and on just just
everybody's we feel like we're lit up
and hugged by the world right now
yeah it's uh it's pretty amazing uh
locally here obviously our family
uh the nation is railing around us and
this is this is
going on around the world so we just
we're so grateful for this platform
really yeah we're great go ahead go
ahead we're grateful that you all took
the time i heard brian you said about
your brother he was someone that liked
to shine the light on people that needed
to have their stories told that he was
that he is an amazing journalist we
thank you for your time this morning
thank you so much gail thank you bye